[Musique]
l'année dernière je vous parlais du
nouveau casque de microsoft du premier
casque de microsoft à l'adduction
bruisser le microsoft surface et folz 1
et là vient de sortir le microsoft
surface iphone de alors vient de sortir
les sorties à quelques temps et ne vous
en parle aujourd'hui dans cette gamme de
casques à réduction de bruit des acteurs
qui sont extrêmement forts extrêmement
puissant sony qui est une des références
probablement la meilleure référence
il ya bien évidemment boss et microsoft
on l'imaginé pas arriver dans l'aude ou
alors ils sont arrivés l'année dernière
avec un premier cas ce qui était
intéressant et notamment au niveau des
commandes venues targuer d'avoir ma
première vidéo si ce n'est pas déjà le
cas et là avec cette version est bien
ils sont venu corriger les points qui
étaient des points assez faibles et
assez négatif la qualité du son a été
retravaillé il n'y avait pas d'
équaliseur pour venir personnaliser
l'expérience
c'est chose faite au travers d'une
application c'est tout vous montrer et
donc eu des points vraiment améliorée et
malgré tout ce casque il info quelques
faiblesses mais en terme d'expérience il
est le seul à proposer quelque chose que
j'aime beaucoup et je voulais taille
dans quelques secondes mais avant toute
chose je vous invite à venir vous avez
notre petit mouton que vous avez là le
petit bouton rouge
c'est ce que je vous parle bien
évidemment de caste je vous parle de
smartphone vous présente tous les
nouveaux objets collector enfin pas tous
mais beaucoup en tout cas et des objets
extrêmement intéressant et je vous parle
de vous de votre vie numérique dont vous
invite à vous de cliquer sur le petit
bouton rouge que vous avez la haac
sonner la cloche comme ça pousse
notifier dès qu'une nouvelle vidéo
rivera et ça c'est vachement bien
j'aime bien en tout cas l'idée de ce
casse l'esthétique on retrouve vraiment
ses courbes comme ça sur le côté c'est
propre à ce casque microsoft cette année
il ya une nouveauté est bien c'est qu'il
est venu en noir les dernières on avait
dans une seule couleur cette année on a
ces deux couleurs noir qui vivent bien
arriver qu'un peu plus passe partout qui
reste très élégante normalement le petit
code-barres vous n'avez pas c'est un
matériel de près et là c'est
effectivement pour venir à l'éthique t
on va retrouver des mousse à mémoire de
forme avec des petits coussinets qui
sont vraiment très très confortable je
vous parle du confort dans quelques
instants on a le logo microsoft ici on a
ici leur ait convoi on a le left de
l'autre côté ici vous avez néanmoins un
petit arsenal réglé sur votre tête très
très facilement nombreux termes
d'esthétique c'est très bien il est
fourni avec une petite boîte très
sympathique vous venez large et là vous
mettez vos petits câbles vous avez un
petit cap pour venir le charger en usb
sévère de lui
de l'autre côté vous avez une petite
prise jack date convenant à brancher sur
un baladeur sur ce que vous voulez et
vous venez pour angers là dedans c'est
pratique c'est sympa ça fonctionne bien
c'est un casque qui vient se positionner
très facilement et qui déjà comme ça
vient vous couper un peu de l'extérieur
il vient complètement englober votre
oreille là vous avez déjà une réduction
passive comme ça de moins 40 décibels
confort est assez bon on sent légèrement
ici une petite pression mais c'est pas
très grave vous venez le relever un peu
comme ça et en termes de confort c'est
très très bien alors on n'est pas aussi
confortable que ce qu'on pourrait
retrouver avec un casque de solides
notamment le wsj nixon trois halls w/h
mix n 4 mais malgré tout sur les écoute
prolongée
ça fera très très bien la faire lorsque
vous venez allumez votre casque avec le
petit bouton vous faites un appui 3h
d'autonomie restantes connecter un
iphone aurélien donc vous voyez déjà
elle vient vous parlez vous avez une
jolie petite voix qui a coûté un peu
robotique surnom du smartphone iphone
aurélien mais par contre c'est bien
lorsque vous l'allumez vous savez
exactement ce qui vous reste en tant que
musique là il ya un côté pratique alors
maintenant ce que j'aime tout de suite
je vais vous le dire directement c'est
pour moi le casse qui propose la
meilleure expérience au niveau des
boutons la meilleure expérience vraiment
et je pèse mes mots quand je dis ça je
vous explique pourquoi
parce que d'un côté comme de l'autre
vous avez ici des petite molette alors
la molette la voix sur le côté là qui
tombe elle va vous permettre de régler
le son quand vous êtes sur le tabac vous
avez un petit sans doute
et lorsque vous montez votre côté vous
avez un sens très aigu volume maximum ça
vous le dis ça c'est extrêmement
intuitif
vous êtes par exemple je sais pas moi en
train d'écouter de la musique pop en
baisse à le morceau suivant j'adore vite
je monte un peu et c'est extrêmement
précis et c'est vraiment bien et de
l'autre côté
eh bien vous avez votre réduction de
bruit suppression du bruit maximum donc
là ça va vraiment venir vous coupé de
l'extérieur et après vous baissez tout
doucement vous dînez vote réduction de
bruit sont filtrés et en redescendant
encore un peu et là vous avez un seau
ambiant amplifié ça vous permet
d'entendre vraiment tous cas autour de
vous et ça marche bien on entend
vraiment vraiment très très bien tout ce
qui à côté vous avez dans votre bouton
pour venir l'allumé peau tendre et ici
vous avez un petit bouton qui est assez
bien vu c'est un petit bouton pour venir
miu t votre micro lorsque vous êtes en
appel téléphonique
vous parlez à quelqu'un vous appuyez
dessus ça désactivé à votre micro et on
vous entendra plus et a contrario pour
venir appuyer et ça permettra de
reprendre connotation de là vous en
étiez à côté de ça voyez c'est assez
minimaliste et c'est très efficace en
terme d'expérience aujourd'hui c'est pas
trouvé mieux sur aucun cas ce qu'en plus
vous avez ici sur le côté c'est un pavé
tactile il son côté s'est également
les tactiles vous faites un appui plague
un autre appui pose deux tapes morceau
suivant 3 tape morceau précédent
lorsqu'on vous appelle vous appuyé deux
fois pour décrocher pour refuser vous
appuyez et vous maintenez et lorsque
vous n'êtes pas en appel vous appuyez
vous maintenez ça veut dire déclenché
votre assistant vocal assistant vocal
pas forcément cortana suivi sur iphone
ça va être syrie c'est peut être google
assistant sur android et si vous êtes
sur windows 6 parce que oui vous pouvez
effectivement le relier à votre windows
disent eh bien vous aurez cortana et aux
deux points qui est cool et non des
moindres lorsque vous l'avez sans vos
oreilles et que vous avez de la musique
vous l'enlever il va couper la musique
pour parler avec quelqu'un ou je ne sais
quoi encore et bien hop vous leur mettez
la musique repart donc en terme
d'expérience pur et dur c'est vraiment
quelque chose que j'adore et c'est pour
moi et je vous le dis une fois de plus
la meilleure expérience au niveau de
l'utilisation des boutons les molettes
je suis extrêmement fans des molettes
microsoft ça j'adore j'aimais déjà
beaucoup dans la première version
et là je continue d'adorer dans cette
deuxième version avoir un bon casque
avoir de belles commandes tactiles c'est
bien mais le plus important c'est
d'avoir une bonne qualité sonore une
bonne qualité audio et un monde
lorsque je les écoute je prends je
n'allume je le mets c'est flatte
d'ailleurs sans aucune correction grâce
à l'éco heather de l'application et ça
je vous en parle en quelques instants
eh bien je trouve que le son est un peu
étouffée et qu'il manque un peu de
précision
donc je prends mon application je vous
la montre et vous allez voir est
vraiment cool et grâce à ça j'ai pouvoir
venir corriger et améliorer le son et
c'est pour moi ce qui fait la différence
et c'est tout le problème qu'on avait
notamment dans la première version
le son sera nettement meilleur
personnellement je suis monté un peu les
médiums et un peu les aigus pour
apporter un peu plus de brillance et
avoir un son qui respire davantage on a
un fond dans l'ensemble qui est qualité
mais on ne va pas aussi loin que ce
qu'on peut retrouver avec les leaders du
marché notamment se retrouve du côté de
chez sony avec le wh1 nixon 3 ou encore
le double des slicks n 4 mais malgré
tout il ya un vrai beau travail qui est
essayé de la part de microsoft là dessus
et ça il faut vraiment le saluer après
les corrections retrouve des médiums qui
sont assez précis des élus à ses fins on
va rapidement bien reconnaître des soins
aigus des cymbales qui vont vraiment
revenir mais il faut venir les monter un
petit peu parce qu'elles sont un peu
trop étouffée par dans son médium grave
qui va peut venir vous le vous le vul
casser un peu comme ça ça c'est un peu
dommage après ça dépendra bien
évidemment de ce que vous aimez
de votre style d'ecoute de type de
correction vous aimez on peut faire
quelque chose ne fait pas non plus la
magie est un autre point qui est
important c'est que même lorsque vous à
l'écouté à fort volume
attention à vos ordres et une fois de
plus et bien vous allez pas avoir un
casque qui va venir sa cure et on aura
une bonne restitution du son et mais
lorsque vous écoutez à faible volume
sczepaniak c'est parfait parce que c'est
pas vrai on va venir perdre un peu cette
précision au niveau des aigus parce
qu'il faut que vos haut-parleurs puisse
travailler c'est de la physique à il
faut qu'ils puissent bouger pour
délivrer du son donc il faut venir lui
apporter un peu de puissance derrière
mais lorsque vous arrivez qu'une
puissance modérée jusqu'à un son qui est
très élevé ça ne sature pas et la
restitution sera vraiment très juste
mais croissance à travers le sortir une
application surface audio vous y
retrouver notamment des informations sur
votre appareil votre/vos lui la
réduction de bruit élevé moyen bas où
sons ambiants amplifié alors ici toi
qu'un petit peu surprenant et vous ne
pouvez pas avoir de réduction de bruit
qui est complètement supprimée sans
aucun son ambiant amplifié c'est pas
possible vous avez forcément quelque
chose qui active et élevée moyen bas où
sons ambiants amplifié pour les
personnes qui seraient allergiques à ça
et bien voyez pas que vous l'avez vous
n'avez pas le choix vous allez enfin
savoir votre équaliseur et ça pour moi
c'est ce qui est plus intéressant par
défaut vous êtes en flac comme ça moi ce
que j'ai fait au niveau de la correction
j'ai monté mais aiguë aiguë médiums
aigus
j'ai monté les médiums j'ai cassé un
petit peu ici mais megan grave et j'ai
très légèrement monté mais grave
vous pouvez venir les modifier voulait
enregistrer pouvez en créer un autre
équaliseur et vous aviez par mail sont
pré réglés mais c'est de pouvoir avoir
vos réglages à vous comme vous le
souhaitez chaud ça vraiment bien la
réduction de bruit parlons-en pendant
des très bonnes réductions bruit on ira
peut-être pas une fête plus aussi loin
que ce qu'on peut retrouver avec sony
qui est le leader de la réduction de
bruit au niveau des casques audio
l'objectif chose qui marche vraiment
bien et une fois de plus le fait d'avoir
cette molette là c'est tout simplement
extraordinaire
si vous fermez profiter d'un fonds de
qualité sans avoir à subir les nuisances
extérieures
microsoft a fait une très très belle
montée en gamme là dessus et en termes
de réduction de bruit
le job est fait à l'intérieur est soit
retrouvé un haut parleur de chaque côté
de 40 mm côté que dès qu'on a pas foule
on va retrouver du sbc qu'on avait
l'année dernière on va trouver de
l'appétit kz2 qualcomm mais si on n'a
pas de passé et bien évidemment on n'a
pas de ldc
on aura donc quelque chose qui sera
moins fournis que ce que vous allez
pouvoir retrouver à la concurrence et
moi il ya un truc que je trouve vraiment
intéressant que j'aime bien et on voit
que c'est microsoft derrière c'est
qu'avec ce casque là lorsque vous l'avez
sur votre tête je fais sortir derrière
les oreilles eh bien vous êtes voir
l'utiliser pour travailler et notamment
une fête plus comme celle microsoft il
vous créez
applications directement à des qu'office
365 si vous avez un abonnement avec
world a oublié compagnie vous allez
pouvoir avoir de la dictée vocale ce qui
vous permettra d'aller plus loin au
niveau de tout ce qui va être tâches
professionnelles
donc ça c'est un petit plus mais c'est
très malin l'autonomie sera aussi moins
bonnes que se retrouver en concurrence
on va voir jusqu'à 20 heures d'écouté en
bluetooth vous le charger complètement
en deux heures et si vous lui mettez
cinq minutes de charge vous partez au
moins pour une heure du coup tu 20
heures d'autonomie même si c'est parce
qu'elle mieux qu'on peut trouver mieux à
la concurrence personnellement pour moi
ça fera déjà parce que déjà 21 casque
sur les oreilles bon vous le prenez vous
le charger ne serait ce qu'un petit
quart d'heure vous est peinard pour un
bon petit moment
bon ça c'est pas un souci et l'année
dernière il ya un point qui compte c'est
avec ce casque c'est quand ils l'ont
sorti on était au prix des meilleures du
marché
on était à 380 je sais plus exactement
dans cette fourchette là et ça marchait
pas ça pouvait pas coller parce que
quand on avait presque 400 euros à
mettre dans un casque est quand même une
très très grosse somme
on n'allait pas les sur un casque qui
même s'il était plutôt bien on n'allait
pas mettre ce prix là on allait sur ce
qui se faisait de mieux donc microsoft a
revu sa copie et a positionné son casque
à 279 euros
279 euros 99 pourrait très près c'est
donc quasiment de 180 euros ce qui est
vraiment bien il ya un très très bel
effort de fait il ya une montée en gamme
il progresse et ils baissent le prix
donc un vrai bel effort qui est fait là
dessus de la part de microsoft
maintenant aujourd'hui le problème c'est
que on regarde ce qui se passe en face
une fois de plus à la concurrence sony a
sorti son w/h mxn 4 d'auto parlera des
sites quelques jours et du coup le wh1
mg 3 a diminué et on le retrouve à 299
euros alors il est toujours un peu plus
cher que lui mais l'écart n'est pas
énorme et surtout il en fait beaucoup
plus
alors la question m et bien vers le
canal est est ce que ce cas cela je peux
vous le recommander à style intéressant
pour moi la réponse est oui
maintenant la question c'est si vous
hésitez entre un double dash xl 3 et 1
surface est folle
2 eh bien ça à ce délicat moi ce que
j'aime vraiment sur ce casque c'est
toute l'expérience que vous avez au
niveau des commandes et ça pour moi
c'est un must son wmx m3 j'ai jamais
réussi à utiliser les commandes pour
monter le son je veux c'est une vraie
galère c'est pas très intuitif c'est
toujours par l'application ou par maman
pour piloter pour mettre plein pot et
compagnie donc ça c'était pas où mais ça
ne plaisait pas énormément là dessus par
contre c'est très bien vu très
l'un est très très bien réalisé de la
part de microsoft je vous le dis une
fois de plus je suis vraiment très très
amoureux de sa le fait d'être comme ça
de venir monter son décès elles sont
gérées sa réduction de bruit d'un côté
l'autre rappelle et compagnie c'est
juste génial et microsoft a vraiment
très très bien travaillé là dessus
maintenant et c'est le problème
sony avec son double des chemises xm3
proposera un confort qui sera un peu
meilleur que celui ci comme je viens
vidéo test du surface et funk version 1
lorsqu'on enlève ce cas ce que là et
qu'on met le casque sony on a
l'impression d'être des pantoufles donc
on a vraiment un confort qui est
optimale la qualité du son sera
également meilleur avec le casque sony
mais pour moi là-dessus l'expérience
sera meilleur maintenant c'est à vous de
savoir à vous de voir
je vous conseille d'aller les essayer
ces casques aller dans n'importe quel
magasin
mettez les sur votre tête écoutez les
voyez ce qui est vraiment important pour
vous en tout cas et ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'avec cette version numéro deux du
surface et funds et bien microsoft
continue à mettre le pied dans la cour
des grands je pense que la 3 sera pas
l'aboutissement mais en tout cas quelque
chose qui permettra d'être vraiment
frontale avec les autres il ya une très
très très belle amélioration entre la v1
la v2 moi j'aime beaucoup
ils ont gardé les points qui étaient
très forts ils ont retravaillé pas mal
de choses et c'est extrêmement
encourageant à vous de me dire vous
maintenant ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire personnellement j'aime
bien tout ce que microsoft travaille
bien c'est pas dans le bon sens et ce en
tout cas c'est vachement cool sur ce je
vous embrasse vamour beaucoup d'amour et
à très vite certains
[Musique]
il